في مكان ما في ركن فالون هذا من ساحة
المعركة غير المنسية ، هناك ستة
جنود أوكرانيين مفقودين يعتقدون أن
ليونارد بوندار وفريق التعافي العسكري المكون من رجلين قد جاءوا للبحث عنهم.
هم أول من يبحث منذ أن
استعادت أوكرانيا هذه المنطقة من
القوات الروسية قبل ستة أسابيع
أخطار تكثر الألغام القاتلة.  لقد
جاء الفريق لحل
نعم
الحياة انتهت في لحظة الآن ربما
لم تنته قصصهم ، لقد
توصلنا إلى إمكانية
تحليق الجثث بعد الانفجار ،
وبالتالي وجدنا بقايا مقاتلين آخرين
بحلول نهاية اليوم الأول ،
وجدت بوندا أدلة و  شيء آخر أيضًا
كان يخشى من الوحشية الروسية ،
حيث توجد أجزاء معدنية من
علب الذخيرة هنا وشظايا العظام قطعة
ربما من قطعة ساق من الجمجمة
هنا ، يعتقد المحققون أنه
ربما حاول الروس حرق الجثث
في اليوم التالي ، حيث قام الفريق
بالحفر فيها.  المخبأ الذي يعتقدون أن
الجنود اختبأوا فيه أثناء القصف
الأجنبي
يجمع عظام جندي ألقي
من الانفجار كل شظية تعثر على
حمض DNA محتمل وعزاء محتمل
لأحبائهم ثم يكتشف حلقة
مفيدة لتحديد الهوية كما يقول ولكن
العظام أيضًا  تأكيدًا لما كان
يخشى أن يحرق الروس
جسد هذا الجندي الذي سقط بقسوة ،
فهذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
نواجه فيها موقفًا
يتم فيه إهمال القواعد الإنسانية والجنود
لم يتم دفنهم بشكل صحيح
في القبو.  بعد
ذلك ،
أخذ الجنود الأوكرانيون الآخرون غير المتوقعين الفريق
إلى جندي روسي ميت اكتشفوه للتو
بالقرب من رفاته التي تم تسجيلها في
نفس الاحترام مثل
سقوطهم
في المخبأ ، المزيد من التقدم عدة
جثث تقع تحت الأنقاض
تأتي على شقيق المنزل ليونارد ويسبرز مثل  جسد
الجندي المكسور بلطف
حر ،
ثم تم نزع وثائق الجندي التالي التي كانت في متناول اليد ،
شكرًا لك على مساعدتنا في التعرف عليك
يخبر الجسد الذي
رأيناه أن خمسة من زملائنا العسكريين
تبقى أسئلة حول جثة واحدة أخرى
عندما نرفعها  سنرى ما إذا كان
هناك أيضًا ، فقد تم
العثور قريبًا على لم شملهم مع
عائلاتهم المفجوعة
لحظاتهم الأخيرة بشكل أفضل فهم
بوندار وفريقه يتعهد بمواصلة
البحث عن المرضى
الذين يعرفون أنهم قد لا يتمكنون من
معرفة كل تفاصيل  كيف
مات هؤلاء الجنود ، الشيء الوحيد المؤكد هنا هو
أنه ما دامت الحرب مستمرة في
عملهم بعيدًا عن
نيك روبرتسون ، فرشاة سي إن إن كيفكا أوكرانيا.